- Bladesmiths, this
The wooden ramrod chop.
To test the strength and
durability of your edge,
as well as the overall
construction of your knives,
I'll be chopping into
this ramrod 10 times.
Bob, you're up first, you ready?
No, but let's do it.
BEN ABBOTT: All right.
BOB: Naturally I'm nervous.
My concern on the
wooden ramrod chop
is that the edge rolls or
maybe the blade breaks.
Steel is a finicky
little critter.
Sometimes it works
real good, sometimes
it just snaps in your face.
You'll never know
until you test it.
[chops ramrod] [music playing]
There she goes.
Feel like a punch in the gut.
BEN ABBOTT: Well, Bob, quite
obviously your plane broke.
Whoops.
BEN ABBOTT: And
looking at your grain,
I would like to have
seen thermal cycling
done to your blade.
The grain that
I'm seeing in here
is a lot more coarse
than I would like to see.
And that blends to a
more brittle blade.
WIL WILLIS: Bob,
your blade suffered
a critical failure
in the very first
strike of the very first test.
However, in order to proceed,
two more bladesmith's still
have to make it
through this test.
Bob, you're not out yet.
Gentlemen, your blades are made
out of the exact same steel.
Let's see if they hold up.
Ben?
BEN ABBOTT: Daniel,
you're up next.
Feeling lucky?
- I reckon so.
BEN ABBOTT: All right.
[music playing]
DANIEL: Everything about
the steel in my blade
and in Bob's blade is identical.
The thing that scares me right
now is if I got this thing too
hard, the first time he
hits that ramrod it's
going to shatter like glass.
[chops ramrod]
[music playing]
BEN ABBOTT: Well, Daniel,
it held up very well.
The edge is just not quite
as sharp as it was before.
But there's no rolls,
there's no chipping.
This was impressive
to watch you do.
This is your second blade.
DANIEL: Thank you sir.
- Collin, you're up.
You ready?
I'm jealous.
I want to swing it.
And I'm just like, oh.
[beep] You can't look away.
It's like a car wreck.
You just lock in.
[chops ramrod]
[music playing]
[beep] Well, we're
in the same camp now.
[slow intense music playing]
BEN ABBOTT: Well Collin,
your knife broke, obviously.
The grain structure in
here is sort of in between.
It's not quite as
coarse as I've seen,
but it's certainly not the
finest grain I've ever seen.
The thing that's
really telling is
there was a Mig weld that went
across here to hold this piece
of mild steel on the side.
Right next to it there is this
bronze line, and what that
tells me is that that
was a surface crack
there before the heat treat.
That's why it broke,
where it broke.
WIL WILLIS: Daniel, you'll be
moving on to the final round.
Congratulations.
Collin, Bob, both of your blades
suffered catastrophic failures
in our strength test.
Collin, your blade
lasted longer than Bob.
Bob, your blade suffered
that catastrophic failure
in one stroke.
And for that reason
I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
[music playing]
BOB: If you've never broken
a blade as a bladesmith,
you have a bladesmith.
I have no regrets.
This is merely a
stumbling block when
you're walking down the street.
You get up, you dust yourself
off, and you move on.
I came here to prove
that I can make
a knife under strenuous
conditions in three hours.
I did that.
Win or lose.
I did it.